[Music]
on this Sunday night a terrifying
twister tears through an Alberta
Community what did you hear just
everything
just the house is crumbling the
devastation and stories from survivors
unrelenting unrest in France
why declaring a state of emergency may
be pointless and the new investigation
into an attack on a politician's family
the sound of money
what's making concerts so costly and why
cities are banking on big music Acts
plus Dynamite
the Saskatchewan Community roaring into
the record books
for an answer
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us a
small Alberta Community is recovering
tonight from a powerful tornado that
ripped through the region yesterday
the Twister touched down in Mountain
View County located roughly halfway
between Calgary and red deer destroying
multiple properties and while only minor
human injuries have been reported dozens
of animals have died in the storm's wake
Carolyn Curry de Castillo surveyed the
destruction and spoke with people who
now have no place to call home including
one man who rescued his mother from the
wreckage
there's nothing left of the home Diane
and Ray Kelsey lived in north of car
stairs farm equipment was picked up and
tossed half a kilometer away trees
uprooted she was well pretty much buried
in the basement and my son he got her
out
so without getting too terrible
emotional here he he's a hero in my eyes
Ray wasn't at home when the tornado
touched down but his wife was and so was
his son who lives across the highway
what did you hear just everything
just the house just crumbling Travis
Kelsey and his wife and baby took
shelter in the basement as soon as he
could he rushed over to bring his mom to
safety there was nothing the house was
flat but I just wanted my mom out I
don't want to be a hero or anything the
tornado caused damage to nine homes of
which three were completely destroyed
around 25 cows were killed or had to be
put down but no one was seriously
injured it was a total disaster I hate
to say it but it's just right out of the
movies just like the movie Twister it
was just leveled I'm telling you I just
started to cry it was devastating to see
my childhood property just totally
demolished
devastating but and in the same token I
also know that we're going to be okay
and it's only stuff tornado expert
Connell Miller says compared to other
tornadoes typically seen in Canada this
is a more significant event with more
damage and had the potential to cause
far more destruction two kilometers that
way there's a big subdivision and a
kilometer that way there's an old
trailer park right and it's amazing that
none of that got hit and it's amazing
that the people that did experience this
tornado weren't more injured than they
were twister was on the ground for at
least 20 minutes and also resulted in
hail damage Carol and Curry de Castillo
Global News
and the plowing came through and took
the top of the tree right off onto the
roof
that same low pressure system that
caused the tornado in Alberta made its
way to Saskatchewan Environment Canada
says several storms carrying Winds of
almost 100 kilometers an hour ripped
through the province yesterday the
storms hit multiple areas including
Meadow Lake Battleford and the prince
Albert National Park region the winds
eventually died out near the Manitoba
border so far there have been reports of
power outages minor structural damages
downed trees and golf ball-sized hail
a strong storm also wreaked havoc in
Quebec where two people a man and a
woman are missing after being Swept Away
by a landslide the community of riviere
Eternity about three hours north of
Quebec City declared a state of
emergency on Saturday after the slide
collapsed parts of a major highway
Environment Canada says about 130
millimeters of rain fell within two
hours there are new calls for calm in
France where protesters have stormed the
streets for another night outraged over
last week's police killing of a teenage
boy near Paris
police arrested about 700 people
Saturday that's about half compared to
Friday the biggest confrontations
between Riot police and demonstrators
took place in Marseille the country's
second largest city
as the grandmother of 17 year old naelle
merzuk asks for the rioting to stop
police have opened a new case as Redmond
Shannon reports they've launched an
attempted murder investigation after an
attack against the family of a French
mayor
a new escalation in the violent protests
that have seized France since Tuesday
authorities say rioters rammed a car
into the home of the mayor of Lele Rose
a suburb of Paris then shot fireworks at
his wife and young children as they fled
the mother is believed to have broken
her leg during the
ordealifications
the regional prosecutor says the attack
is being investigated as attempted
murder
on Sunday locals offered support to the
mayor who was at the Town Hall when it
happened Jean brune says it will be
three months before his wife can walk
again
before that eruption of violence it had
been a slightly quieter night in France
with about half the previous night's
arrests still numbering more than 700
seething anger against alleged police
brutality and racism after the shooting
of 17 year old Niel merzouk
imagine if it happened to my brother we
are not safe here says this woman
but the heartbroken grandmother of the
Dead teen says enough is enough
I blame the police officer who killed my
grandson that's all I'm angry with and
the people who are breaking things I
tell them stop it stop it they're doing
this with nail as a pretext as president
Emmanuel macron held another crisis
meeting the tone from many lawmakers is
toughening what's happening uh is ultra
Violence by small groups of people that
are very well organized and very well
trained and they want to defy the
Republic and the Republic will not yield
and we will fight back macron's dilemma
is that declaring a state of emergency
to give police more Powers May escalate
the already palpable anger against those
very officers Redmond Shannon Global
News London
more than a week after Wagner's
attempted coup threatened to derail
moscow's war on Ukraine Russia resumed
airstrikes on Kiev overnight
this is the first such attack on the
Ukrainian capital in 12 days military
officials there say exploding drones and
cruise missiles targeting the city were
all shot down one person was injured by
debris fighting is intensifying in
Ukraine's counter-offensive with the
push seeing some progress around bakmut
and Southern regions despite Russian
resistance
in the U.S another mouse shooting has
left two people dead and dozens more
injured in Baltimore the killings
happened early this morning when gunfire
erupted at a block party police believe
at least two gunmen were responsible no
arrests have been made the victims were
an 18-year-old woman and 20-year-old man
they were among at least 28 people
including multiple children who were
shot three people are in critical
condition tonight
more than seven thousand BC port workers
are off the job for a second day
federal government must stay out of our
business if the bcmea
gets their way and their way is to let
the government make this Collective
Agreement for them there will never be
labor Peace On the Waterfront workers
have been without a contract since March
the union says the bcmea has refused to
negotiate on the main issues for its
part the employers Association says it's
tried to be flexible as David Aiken
explains given the port's significance
to the Canadian economy pressure is
mounting on the federal government to be
more assertive in ending the strike
week in week out the port of Vancouver
plays a central role in Canada's and
indeed the world's Supply Chains It's
where Canada's canola grain potash and
other exports head to Asian markets and
it's where consumer and Manufacturing
Goods begin their journey to Canadian
destinations more than 13 percent of
Canada's overseas trade or 300 billion
dollars a year is handled by Pacific
ports
but for the second day in a row the
ports in BC are quiet brought to a
standstill by workers striking for
better pay and job security in an era of
automation so if there's a long
disruption then then we then we can
start to see
um uh Supply chains getting blocked and
production getting halted and that could
have a knock-on negative effect on the
country's economic reputation worried
about that kind of long-term economic
damage the Canadian Chamber of Commerce
on Sunday argued that Parliament should
be recalled to pass Back To Work
legislation and other business groups
agreed believing the union timed the
strike for maximum effect quite back
people into a corner instead of uh of
actually negotiating sooner I think it
deserves uh Parliament being recalled
the federal government will have no
choice but to introduce a Back To Work
legislation if this contain news
for a few more days it's impossible to
have the BC ports being not fully
operational for more than a few days the
Trudeau liberals did use Back To Work
legislation to end a strike at the Port
of Montreal in 2021 but for now the
government does not appear ready to
intervene labor Minister Sheamus
o'reagan is in Vancouver and said
Saturday the best deals for both parties
are reached at the table the NDP
opposition agrees well I think
everyone's well aware of the stakes
involved here when it comes to Canada's
supply chain and at the same time these
are the workers who got us through the
pandemic and kept the supply chain
running for his part intends to stay in
Vancouver until a deal is reached David
Aiken Global News
Ottawa
still in BC the 16 year old girl who was
lost for more than two days in the
wilderness is now sharing her story
Esther Wang went hiking with three
others on Tuesday in a statement she
says she took a wrong turn separating
her from her group then fell down part
of a mountain while trying to backtrack
after surviving too cold scary and
lonely nights in the woods Wang says she
eventually found her way back by
identifying landmarks from photos she
had taken this is the teen after she
emerged from the forest Thursday night
aside from minor injuries weighing his
home and unharmed and thanks everyone
who tried to help find her
the enduring Allure despite pricey
performances coming up how concerts are
costing more than ever yet not stopping
fans from spending big on the shows
plus looking back on pride month and
what growing protests against the lgbtq2
plus Community could meet
[Music]
inflation is affecting everything these
days from food to fuel and even fun many
people are shelling out big bucks to see
their favorite singer in concert and
that's music to the ears of businesses
and even politicians and gaviola looks
at what's driving up the cost of concert
tickets and the powerful effect
Superstars can have on the economy
whether it's Taylor Swift Beyonce
[Music]
Bruce Springsteen or Shania Twain fans
are sparing no expense for the live
music experience you push the price up
on these concert tickets and people
might complain but they just don't want
to miss out concert ticket inflation is
fueled by many things including higher
costs for putting on these elaborate
Productions that is a reality of the
music business these days because costs
are so much higher since covid and
because nobody is buying music anymore
artists have to make all their money on
the road but ticket sales are one part
of the money making equation add in
merchandise food and drinks parking
maybe even a flight and hotel stay top
acts can move the economic needle Sweden
blamed its higher than expected
inflation rate in May on Beyonce's
concerts Taylor Swift's era's tour has
the potential to generate 4.6 billion
dollars in consumer spending in the U.S
alone enough to prompt Australian
lawmakers to petition her to add what
would be a sixth concert in the country
Adelaide wants a show too by my
six-year-old was very excited and I will
be speaking with all of my colleagues
and potentially doing a grievance in
Parliament next week to try to encourage
Taylor to please come to town Edmonton
MP Matt generous says he's following
Australia's lead and filing an official
grievance to entice Swift to add a
Canadian stop look I could listen to the
music online I could watch music videos
I could do any number of ways to consume
these particular acts but it's the
ability to take a selfie of me in the
crowd saying look where I am acts that
can draw multiple Generations have an
edge whether that's parents attending
with children or new fans and nostalgic
ones people may complain at the
beginning when they oh my God tickets
are so expensive but when you go to the
show and you have the communal
experience and it's with one of your
favorite artists well
then it was worth it you got your
money's worth and gaviola Global News
Toronto
[Music]
sunscreen Savvy ahead we look at some
Summer Skin protection myths and facts
summer is in full swing and as many
people try to spend more time outdoors
in the coming weeks doctors are
reminding people to lather up with
sunscreen as Catherine Ward reports it's
easy to overlook some important factors
when protecting your skin from the Sun
working outside it's super important to
be on top of it pop open the lid
protect yourself it's important and
lather up
now that summer is here experts are
urging people to put on sunscreen often
they say reapplying every two hours at
minimum we recommend an SPF of at least
30. but just looking at the SPF rating
is only one consideration doctors say
looking at the finer details of the
sunscreen label will let you know if
your sunscreen is up to the job
UVB rays are responsible for sunburns
dermatologist Dr Sunil Kalia says most
people don't apply enough sunscreen for
it to be as effective as the SPF rating
suggests and there have been studies
showing that the higher SPF levels of at
least 100 do work better than the 50
preventing like a sunburn reaction or
other
sun-induced reactions just apply it
liberally and really work it into the
Skins to make sure you're getting that
coverage that's so important
Beauty editor Jill Dunn says protection
from UVA rays is also critical they're
known as the Aging Rays the best bet is
a broad spectrum sunscreen that helps
mitigate the risk of both mineral
sunscreens are one option even though
not Everyone likes how they look they do
appear more white on the skin and do not
be tricked by cloudy weather or
advertising unless you're like inside in
a dark room in air conditioning you're
not really blocking the sun it's really
everywhere Sage advice for a safer
summer Catherine board Global News
Toronto
[Music]
month Reflections next how celebrations
in Canada's biggest city wind as
backlash against the lgbtq2 plus
community grows
June was pride month and as the calendar
flips to July it's a chance to take
stock of how things went joining us now
is the executive director of Pride
Toronto Sherwin modest Sherwin thanks
for joining us I'm sure you've been
reflecting on your big event of the year
The Pride Parade how would you describe
the overall experience and success of
that celebration
thank you for having me and I must say
that that you know we
we delivered overall Pride 2023 was a
tremendous success in so many different
ways not just in the talent that we
brought to Toronto but the allyship and
the support that we got for from
Community spoke volume to the support
that is there for the 2s lgbtq community
sure that will be reassuring for many to
hear especially as our conversation
comes at a time of great challenges for
the lgbtq2 plus Community from the
stabbing incident at Waterloo the
defacing of rainbow sidewalks just to
name a few how have you and Toronto
Pride navigated these obstacles and a
general rise in hate
yeah so you know what one of the things
that we did in Toronto was we were very
upfront that there is an increase in
hate in the community we asked the
community to be the community best
security by looking out for each other
but we also were able to put different
security measures in place so we hired
more of our private security to ensure
that our stages our parade our street
fair you know have additional security
so for us it was really important to
send that message but also you know we
were very clear that there is no room in
the festival there is no room in our
society for the hate so I we definitely
think we scare a lot of the the haters
for lack of a better word away
and that's talking about pride month and
the pride parade but looking forward
what are Toronto Pride's goals or plans
in terms of addressing the issue of
anti-lgbtq2 plus hate
yeah no I mean this is this is very
important because now that the festival
is over and the world was present in
Toronto and folks saw what an amazing
Pride we were able to put on I think
this is the time now that we call on all
three levels of government to hold folks
accountable there is no room we can no
longer sit by and just allow that level
of hate to the 2s lgbtq Community
continue so there is going to be a ramp
up of advocacy from Pride Toronto to
ensure that all levels of government are
taking this serious you know no matter
who is at the head they need to take the
hit that is directed towards the to us
lgbtq Community serious
speaking of advocacy Advocates have
spoken out concern for the mental health
and well-being of the lgbtq2 plus
Community what's the sense you've gotten
from your discussions of how people are
doing
you know we had so many requests for
folks saying you know I'm just don't
feel safe coming out and as an
organization we take it serious hence
we're also going to be ramping up our
activities throughout the year having
Pride 365 to create a safe space to
create an Avenue where by which folks
will be able to come out
our conversations will indeed continue
but we'll leave it there for now once
again that's executive director of Pride
Toronto Sherwin modest Sherwin thank you
so much
thank you for having me
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm nitu garcha this long
weekend one Saskatchewan Town celebrated
Canada Day differently than anyone else
this is Dundurn where more than 1100
people showed up for a prehistoric party
setting a Guinness world record for the
biggest Gathering of inflatable dinosaur
costumes smashing the previous record of
380. the town's population is only 675
meaning the town had more dinosaurs than
actual residents I don't know what to
tell you thanks so much for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow have
a great night
[Music]